dans ce désert de glace
la température oscille entre -50 et
moins 62 gré des conditions extrêmes
pour ce bataillon de l'armée canadienne
en mission dans le haut arctique
la photographe emmanuel léonard a
accompagné les soldats dans cette
expédition dans le cadre du programme
d'arts des forces canadiennes
l'opération baptisée nunalivut permet au
canada d'affirmer sa souveraineté sur ce
territoire
il vante par un parent qu en fait en
motoneige puis des campements à travers
lesquels et par moments ils feront
d'autres exercices comme le chantre ce
front là bas et revenir sans doigts
gelés sans orteils gelés ce qui
représente en soi un défi
ces exercices permettent aussi à
à l'armée aux jeunes militaires
d'apprendre à se déployer sur un
territoire qui est finalement assez
hostile du moins la température
évidemment les militaires sont épaulés
dans cette mission par des rangers 6 8
qui leur offrent de précieux conseils
sur comment s'orienter se protéger du
froid
construire des abris une expérience
intense que les soldats ont apprécié ils
ont été impressionnés par la beauté du
paysage l'infini de l'horizon
l'impression d'avancer d'avancé devant
un cm2 fischer jamais atteindre le but
qui paraissent jeu proche mais en
réalité qui signe un parce qu'il n'y a
pas de référence d'une part de distance
est clair si une peu j'adore cette scène
faire des photos et des vidéos par moins
50 degrés
ce sont des défis techniques importants
la photographe devait protéger ces
appareils du froid et de la condensation
attendre des heures pour récupérer son
matériel en sortant de la banquise est
là aussi dû s'adapter au quotidien des
soldats ce qui était un défi pour moi
c'était de suivre ça dure un rythme
d'atteinte et tout à coup on part dans
une minute là avec le matériel est ce
jeu c'est bien sa frappe
cette exposition offre aux visiteurs
l'occasion unique d'accompagner des
soldats fantomatique dans ce territoire
hostile et si peu connu ici catherine
françois radio canada montréal